[Applause]
hey how's it going man i'm good how are
you doing
i'm good i'm good we go way back we go
way back
we wrote together at saturday night live
and we actually shared an office
this is back in the late 1950s when that
show was first it was a radio show then
first getting started
did my snoring bother you not at all
when you'd read a comedy
very nice very nice no we had uh we had
a lot of good times together yeah we did
you've done very well this year's show
of course well thank you so many shows
of all time i think very well
that's very nice to say i just said it i
thought one we're going to edit it out
later
um it's going to be turned into another
comment you haven't uh you have all your
hair
from that time what happened what do you
have a special spray from dell markers
i have a lot of female hormones yeah
that's what keeps my
this big pompadour going i have a uh
powder that i use
oh really my whole head is powdered your
whole head it looks nice you're very
attractive it all fell off like five
years ago
oh really he looks good you look fine
you look you've been working out i i
actually haven't been on for a while
on this show you were what were you on
like about a year ago no no no it's been
longer than that conan
really yeah really i thought it was kind
of odd and i was talking to people in la
and they were saying you know because
rumors get around and
and they were like no you insulted
somebody on the show and i was like
really who did i insult do you remember
this
no i don't know so i went and i found a
clip of it
and i can't figure out who i insulted
well wait how long ago were you on it's
like a long time ago like two years ago
two years ago yeah at least i mean i got
the clip
but i'm one warning it's it's like like
it's old so like
andy richter is still here and the set's
different
but i probably look a little different
you know yeah a little bit
but you know what let's watch it and if
you can tell me who i
insulted please i'll apologize now let's
take a look at this uh clip from the
last time bob was on
[Applause]
[Laughter]
yes great interview great interview
change the subject change the subject
change the subject so bob
your new tv show mrs howe no
it's not mrs howell conan it's mr show
it's on hbo
what it's on hbo i'm also gonna play an
alien on star force
3000 next week i play a pot belly guy
a name fleet you know what this is just
andy's falling asleep over here and this
is just
unprofessional and rude
change the subject change this you
realize you're saying change the subject
changing subject over and over coney
chewing gum
i mean this show max is over there
making those weird noises just to piss
me off
you mean this
yeah yeah it's our theme song yeah well
it sucks
okay and this show the whole show is
going in the toilet if you don't make
some changes
uh yeah and you know what the audience
is a bunch of morons that's what i think
of you
yeah they don't have a response to that
huh yeah some audience we had back then
i don't remember it was only two years
ago
and max why did we have a sign that said
conan show on a bed sheet
that's the only it was the biggest
mistake we made back then
uh you know what i see this is real i
actually thought of that
little bit uh in a dream really you have
a lot of dreams you know how
comedy writers always go i dreamt
something so funny
it's so funny okay what is it what
there's people with cheese for heads
it was so funny at 3am when i was asleep
i still like that one yeah now this is
your first film you've directed
melvin goes to dinner is my first film
and i am um
a filmmaker now yeah which is quite
exciting and i have a theory
yeah you want to hear it sure aim the
camera
at the front of the actor's head
that's known as the face you can come up
with technical terms if you want
but yeah i'm really proud of this little
movie it started as
a just a small film in we shot in los
angeles last year and it's
gone around to festivals everywhere it's
about it's called melvin goes to dinner
and it's about a
group of people who get together for
dinner and they kind of get a little
drunk and they they kind of
don't all know each other and they start
to share really personal things
with each other about their bad
relationships and their
sexual fetishes it's kind of like a porn
with no sex and really good dialogue wow
i'd watch that if you can get some porn
into it
uh now um this has been received well at
film festivals
right we've won a bunch of awards and
we've gone to so many there are so many
festivals conan there's
a ton of them now oh my god every town's
got two or three and
and we we've been to big ones and there
are some really
small festivals and one that i went to
that i actually
taped i made a video of it and i want to
show it to you it's
it's called the frank international film
festival and i i just said yes i think
internationally yeah
i just said yes to every festival sure
and uh so i said yes and we showed up
and it and it's
it's a festival for one guy thrown by
one guy
for himself really yeah frank
frank yeah okay all right i got a clip
of us
at our uh q a session you want to see it
sure we're talking about the movie and
here's what it was like um
so i'm going to open it up to uh
questions are there any questions
yeah frank you me
yeah oh yes this question goes for the
writers
where do you begin is it with characters
characterizations a storyline
something you read somewhere is it a
title is it
a genre and where do you go from there
good question hold on a second from
there
you go into what is going to be viable
as a film
or something that's going to be viable
as a story because
sometimes i've gotten either
sometimes i've got nothing and i'll take
those pages
say what's what's the average for it for
a movie is a thousand and
what 11 pages i told you because you
guys get this all the time
doesn't hold on i know i know i have to
be
that's a fun festival it can feel like
that yes
that's actually on our dvd too is the
the entire frank international film
festival okay uh the dvd melvin goes to
dinner will be in stores next friday bob
odenkirk thank you very much
good man bob thank you thank you
everybody when we come back tom shouse
is here
you